the amount of information that a person
have because he
is using something is huge
so if you are going to go through a
specific procedure you would be happy to
speak with somebody who already done
that right you take a specific
medication you want somebody else who've
done that before so all of those things
happening for us that's
that's life changing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel hillary stanford leap birthright
excel serena partners and in media
partnership with c-tech
all right let's get ready for some
inspiration welcome to 20-minute leaders
and meet amnon baglev the co-founder of
ceo of alike health
amnon was the former president at
checkpoint software technologies and
prior to that he was the founder and ceo
of expert integrated system ltd
amnon began his career in the israeli
air force and holds a bachelor of arts
degree in computer science and
management from tel aviv university and
has continued his studies at the faculty
of medicine school of graduate studies
you do not want to miss this one
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am so
excited for this episode thank you so
much for being here how are you
thank you for having me i'm doing great
thank you
hey i'm known i have the you know
already in my mind like 50 questions i
have to ask you
you've done some
incredible incredible things in an
amazing journey with with twists and
turns
from
flying f-16 planes to being the
president and ceo of expert integrated
systems uh the president of the
well-known checkpoint software
technologies company you know a glory of
of of the startup nation that everybody
knows and most recently now the
co-founder and ceo of like.health with a
few more things in between one of them
that we're going to have to spend some
time talking about uh resuming your
studies as a grad in graduate studies
now in the sackler school of medicine uh
obviously in the world of health in
which you're at so i'm known
if i have to ask you to to look at your
sort of career path
how who are you are you and you know are
you an executive or you an entrepreneur
who who are you
oh i hate labels and i'm not sure that
they always contradict each other
i think i'm a challenger
i don't know if there's terms like that
for people but but uh
i really really enjoy challenge
and the the most important one to
challenge is always yourself right
um but but it's it's really relevant
either you are at the air force um and
you need to challenge yourself every day
when you fly
uh when you build a company like my
first one at expert and and then i moved
to checkpoint which was totally
different that's an enterprise and i
grew a company from about half a billion
dollar in sale to two billion dollar uh
into about 17 billion dollar market cap
company and that's like a totally global
from a very local company to uh
you know i manage about three to four
thousand people all around the globe to
a startup with uh 15 people
that i'm i'm riding my bicycle every day
to work and i enjoy that so
if you ask me what is it at the end of
the day i think it's it's the
the the joyful that you get from
challenging yourself and from
challenging others and you can get the
best out of other if you do it correctly
during the time you learn how to do it
in a better way it's not always like
that sometimes
people
when i was younger was much more harsh
and during time i understand that you
need to balance it but at the end of the
day i think
if you gather around yourself people
that enjoy being challenged then it's a
great fun and then you challenge
yourself and you challenge the
organization
and that's what i do
take me to those moments in which you're
you're deciding that you're embarking on
this new challenge you're learning how
to fly
being president of and grow growing a
huge company founding your own company
before and now and obviously a new
challenge presenting itself
what what
how do you feel during those starting
moments what is it about the challenge
that gets you excited and hooked
so first it's not always fun
just to be fair those challenges
um
but but when you overcome that it's a
great one so i'll give you you know
totally different things i remember
myself i used to i was a squadron uh
deputy commander on on phantom on f4 and
then i i moved to fly to f-16 and you
start almost from scratch
so i have a very good reputation while
doing that in that place and then i
moved to a totally different squadron
and i need to
show like again prove myself from zero
it's not about you don't tried your
reputation
and that was a great fun
but it was at the beginning very
stressful like hey how how does it gonna
happen
the same thing by the way when i
recently as you said i'm doing graduate
studying at the
medical faculty here in tel aviv when
you wake up in the morning and you're
gonna do a test in
bioinformatics like everybody most of
the people there are
the age of my kids
but there's a test and at the end of the
day there is results and you don't want
to fail actually you want to be
a player so
it all comes to the same place where
uh it deserves a lot of hard work
no no um no sweet no gain right there's
no there's no other way to do it and
once you understand that you know
the the you have to go through that way
there's no other way
um but the rewards at the end is amazing
now it goes through failure yes i failed
so many times in my life and that's okay
it's uh it's not fun nobody like to fail
don't don't misunderstand me
but but you once you understand it's
part of life
and you try to to do the best out of it
and if it's successful then it's a great
thing
beautiful
checkpoint software technologies growing
the company as president
for 13 years i believe you know you're
you're really living
you're living the story of checkpoint as
a part of the startup nation it's you
know it's going down in the history
books as you know i believe perhaps that
the first major major breakthrough that
we've made in this global world
what is your role as president in in
that journey how did you experience
those 13 years because i experienced
them from the side you know as a fan but
how do you experience it internally as a
decision maker
so i i joined checkpoint at the end of
2005. not an easy time at checkpoint
surprisingly you know the company itself
still suffer from the
you know uh the the bubble of 2000
so income was basically stable at the
down around 570 million dollar and so
the company didn't grow
um there was a lot of stress from that
perspective and uh
and and when i joined i found like an
amazing assets set of assets like great
technology
um
very loyal customer base
but still you need somehow to pour it
and to find the product market fee that
can allow us to grow so an interesting
story for you
um
i went to meet it and i immediately
understand one thing
that
this company has an amazing technology
but the key source
is not the technology
the key source is understanding your
customer and the go to market will win
and that's still my belief i mean always
people have been like fascinating by
technology look what that technology can
do but
but actually if successful companies
it's not just about the technology you
have to have an asset and value but it's
all about the go to market
so a story
when i joined chuck point i went on a
plane i said bye-bye to my family to
like for 13 years and i spent
roughly 20 times a year abroad
uh all over the world and i went to meet
customers all the time
so i remember myself going to a a
meeting in ohio
with a customer
and we talked about technology and i
asked him if everything is okay and he
said look you're very very expensive
so
i didn't mention before but we at that
time we sold only software purely
software so we sold software we paid
like 20 percent
uh maintenance one-time fee and that's
it
um but then
um so this customer said hey you're very
expensive so i told him it's twenty
thousand dollar why is that so expensive
so you look at the corner and said hey
you see this box over here this is a
nokia nokia used to generate an
appliances for us
i said this is 60 000 i need to replace
it every
four years so this is why it's so
expensive
so it was a discussion why he cannot use
some of our solution
at the end of the day i told him look if
i'm gonna bring you a box
my box with a software and a hardware
included
would you buy it for me
he said definitely i asked him do you
need anything else he said yes i want it
to be one skew i don't want four skews
on the on the on the
catalog only one skew that's very
important for me that shows me that it's
one product so don't try to mess around
with that
i went back to the company
and i opened my own startup within
checkpoint
i went over i bought
server from ibm
for x amount of money i took my software
put them all together create one sku and
start selling them
like
like there was a
like discussion in checkpoint should we
move into hardware or not i just did it
i didn't ask anybody
and after i sold in like 10 or 12
million dollar
then actually everybody understood
that's the right way to go and then we
moved to a place where
everything went to uh selling a product
with hardware and software because it's
easy to the customer to consume it's and
we we basically it's allow us to cross
the first 1 billion dollar in sale
dramatically um so it was a great
success to the company so
those those things are fascinating
you're getting to a place you're
searching for opportunity big
opportunity it's not like small you have
to understand the company and sell it a
billion dollar
to to make another change for 10 million
sounds like great but it doesn't move
the needle i need to grow the company 20
every year
so
and i have multiple stories like that
that sometimes if we have longer time
i'll tell you more about them but
there's amazing if you analyze your
assets and know how to leverage them you
can do a revolutions
and you know i'm known it this this show
again it's about leadership and i'm i'm
curious and interested about you know
all the different facets of leadership
in the military we call it 360 degrees
of leadership right where you're also
leading yourself
and um and one thing that you know that
it sticks with me you know they're
talking about
the you know it's trivial yes you as the
president you have the ability to now go
and and and go on these endeavors but
these are time-consuming endeavors
you're literally building and designing
and manufacturing a product within the
company every hour of amnon costs a lot
of money and you you still decide to go
out on this initiative and uh and and to
and to prove the value of it and i can
only imagine that if you were to come to
the board and to to the management team
ahead of time saying i believe in this
there it may not have gone the same way
and and a lot of that in a lot of that
intrapreneurship is something that i've
been learning is is quite
quite critical especially for companies
in this growth stage that may reach some
stagnation or some logarithmic um
asymptote and so i'm known i have to to
take you more towards you know your
transition from cyber to health
what was that about what's happening
there
so i'm sorry to disappoint you it's
gonna be a very
boring story i didn't have like nobody
that died in my family not the wood from
cancer or something it was much simpler
than that i decided at a certain point
in time that i
i did very good to myself financially
and others and it's time to try to do
other stuff in life and mostly to see if
i can do something big that will will
help the world no as you know people are
growing at the beginning they just need
to survive right bringing home uh food
and stuff afterwards in the in this
chain the next step is to be successful
and the and then the last one is can i
leave a legacy here so good for me i'm
at that stage and um
so i went over to the president of the
uh tel aviv university and told him look
i was a student a very good student to
be fair again this a stuff but i studied
computer science and computer science
first degrees
is basically like school i didn't do any
research or anything like that and
i'm i'm very curious to understand more
about
the academic life and to see if there's
values there that i can take outside and
make make something big out of them
and he said hey this is great i'll
i'll present you with numerous amount of
researcher and you choose one and they
will be happy to work with you
and that's really what happened so
that's brought me to the life science i
didn't plan to do that
and i met a couple of them i chose one
professional professor norm chamron i
like what he's doing he did a um
molecular genetics which quite
fascinating things to learn
and we have numerous discussion like a
brainstorming and then after a couple of
months i said look it's nice but i don't
understand the language it goes back to
the question before if you really want
to do something
you need to understand and in ones
you cannot say hey i'm a great manager
so i can manage everything no i don't i
don't accept that there is there's a lot
of customization need to be done in in
the way of thinking
um and there's a language to speak
language in a broader aspect it's a
multiple fact or something so i said i
really need to understand that more and
basically i spent two years of my life
as a student
i just i i just i i took like a very
massive courses like uh biochemistry and
and cell structure and genetics and
stuff and then i learn everything i can
on everything so nanotechnologies to
bioinformatics to whatever it is
immunotherapy and so forth and the whole
idea was and by the way i did everything
like every other student i did exams i
did seminars i i really i was older than
the professors there they always look
when they get to the room the first day
they look who is this guy with their
white hair
uh but
but it gave me so much background
because the the difference between
health care and um
and and cyber is huge the overall health
care is is is a statistical
uh science and the ratio between signal
is noise is very bad it's not like it's
not determinist by any mean
and it's interesting because once i
understand that very deeply
statistically
i found out that
roughly about 30 percent of people
react to a specific treatment
only 30 percent more or less by the way
placebo about 20
so it's not too much different
surprisingly or not
and and that's lead me to a question so
can i do something about it
can i found a better way to look
at people and cluster them differently
and then i came across a technology
called patient similarity network
and that's ai that's what you're going
to might do in stanford so the idea was
can i cluster people
based on similarity
because if you look at the way
physicians look at people they look them
on a specific condition
so if they have ibd then
gastroenterology will look at them and
whatever so he that's what he sees
but people
are much more complex anymore right and
it's not only that
there's an amazing article from mckinsey
that shows that if i'm looking at all
things that affect my health
so genetics is about 20
my my uh clinical data is about 30
and 50
relate to my social determinants
where do i leave my social economic
status how do i sleep at night do i do
sport
uh my social interaction do i have
friends
all of that it's extremely important
so
then i asked myself can i start
collecting information
from multiple aspects profile a person
and then match it with other person
now another thing that i found out
that i don't want
to sell technology to healthcare
providers or insurance or whatever
that's the most tedious
non-scalable thing and if you want to do
something big
you have to do it a very very
differently
you need to
go directly if you want to make a
revolution
then the best way to do a revolution is
going directly to the patient go
directly to the consumer
now it brought me a totally different
challenge
i know how to sell
on a b2b
for
billions of dollars
but b2c is a totally different animal
which i need to uh study from sketch
yeah a new challenge an amazing one by
the way really an amazing one
so you really need to go through another
journey
and and that's what we're doing today
we're actually
building um a social network that it's
based on clinical data
it's all anonymized it's very secure
and it's amazing to see we have
um
a couple of uh um like
tens of thousands of of users already in
the system
and every day when i wake up in the
morning i just look at them and see how
they talk with each other and people are
asking questions other people are
healthy helping them which is
fascinating to see
the amount of information that a person
have because he
is using something is huge
so if you're to go through a specific
procedure you would be happy to speak
with somebody who already done that
right you take a specific medication you
want somebody else who've done that
before so all of those things happening
for us that's
that's a life-changing so that's that's
really what happened now and it's it's
so rewarding by the way
uh it's really great fun
i can only imagine i'm not the you know
both obviously at the end it's improving
their lives because they're able to to
to have better information make better
decisions
but also just on a psychological and
mental capacity level there the
confidence building that this provides
and i'm relating this to something that
is much less important to buy but as i
think it's a relevant example
when i learned how to stall an airplane
and get out of it you know i would talk
with the instructors and i would read
online but those small conversations i
would have with other student pilots
that were that did this lesson last week
and are going through the same
experience as i am
they raised my confidence they they i
felt like i was talking to somebody
who's going through the same thing as me
it was a very different experience than
talking to a doctor or talking to an
instructor right absolutely
doctor doctor do not experience
he he can get some information second
hand but he himself did not experience
exactly the same
things as as a patient
they said that no not that they have the
time or the energy or the incentive to
spend so much time with you but they
sometimes just do not know the
information
and and this you know i saw two people
talking about how to put their
continuous sugar monitoring libra to
their hand and how to stick it to what
will be the patch to stick it when they
go to the shower
or somebody else saying look i have a
ibd flare right now and i concern about
uh uh what should i eat or not right now
or just people talking hey i'm gonna go
to my therapist and i'm i'm afraid from
him and i need some like mental help
so you can see
all of those things happening uh both
asking for specific advice or
more of a like just just going to and
talk with somebody who is with you so
you don't feel alone even that
significant importance for them and that
obviously goes back to
you know the previous sake very quick
comment but relevant one that
30 percent of patients react a certain
way to a treatment 25 percent react a
certain way to with a placebo and and
obviously you know the the effects of a
placebo are we're talking about the
cognitive and the psychological aspects
of a treatment
and and this is in as far as i'm
concerned this is a part of the
treatment this is a part of the process
and and i'm not i'm personally very very
inspired not just about what you do with
the like health
but by the journey as a whole and
growing up in a house with with a
mentality very similar to the one that
you exhibit here the challenger
mentality and and understanding that
it's not always fun but it's rewarding
and that's the excitement that that we
can have and and taking on new different
experiences like this show for me um
to me this conversation was in inspiring
in many many ways and i have way too
many questions uh but i unfortunately
called this 20-minute leader so i have
to to say goodbye and just thank you for
your time and thank you for the amazing
work you're doing for the world
thank you so much and thank you so much
for for the kind interview and and thank
you for having me of course
thank you
[Music]
you